Netflix might be the top dog when it comes
to online video subscription services, but
Amazon Prime Video is mounting a real challenge
to that title.
In fact, Amazon Prime actually has more subscribers,
though many of them haven't even checked out
the company's video service.
If you're one of those people, or you're just
wondering what exactly they have to offer,
here's a look at some of the hidden gems available
on Amazon Prime Instant Video.
Paradise Lost: The Child Murders at Robin
Hood Hills
If you love true crime dramas, then don't
miss your chance to watch this gripping and
moving documentary about one of the most notorious
multiple killings in recent history.
Paradise Lost chronicles the tale of the "West
Memphis Three" — three teenagers tried and
convicted for the murders of three boys in
West Memphis, Arkansas.
"I think the cops just can't find who done
it, and they gotta put it on somebody."
It's a chilling look at both the brutal murders,
and the witch hunt that led to convictions
against the three suspects, who were finally
released from prison nearly two decades later.
"So like I'm the West Memphis Boogie Man.
Little kids will be looking under their bed
before they go to bed. They be puttin me under there."
Monster
Roger Ebert called Charlize Theron's portrayal
of serial killer Aileen Wuornos in Monster
"one of the greatest performances in the history
of the cinema."
Theron ended up winning 17 awards for the
role, including the Academy Award and Golden
Globe for Best Actress, with many critics
and audience members failing to even recognize
Theron thanks to a truly transformative performance.
"So I'm real good with people and um, um I
know how to work a rolodex."
The harrowing true crime story isn't for everyone,
but if you love quality cinema, it might be
for you.
Adventureland
Jesse Eisenberg, Kristen Stewart, Kristen
Wiig, and Bill Hader headline Adventureland,
an irreverent comedy set at a rundown amusement
park.
"You don't know what I'm capable of!
Come on!
Please!"
At times touching and sweet, at others uproariously
funny, Adventureland is a great summer coming-of-age
flick that mixes nostalgia with offbeat humor
to create an unexpectedly moving movie experience.
"What the hell was that?"
"It's just my life."
Selma
In this critically acclaimed historical drama,
Selma takes us on a journey to 1965, as Dr.
Martin Luther King and other voting rights
activists lead protesters on a 54-mile-long
march from Selma to Montgomery, Alabama.
By highlighting racial injustice with these
marches — some of which were televised as
troopers beat and attacked the protesters
— the disenfranchisement of black voters
finally came to an end after the passage of
the Voting Rights Act later that year.
Selma doesn't pull any punches, and dramatically
depicts the brutalization and killing of activists
and innocents in a seminal moment of American
history that resonates as strongly now as
ever.
Under the Skin
Scarlett Johansson delivers a spellbinding
performance in Under the Skin as a mysterious
alien who preys on men in Scotland.
The movie takes on the alien's perspective
of our world, and she exhibits callous disinterest
in the things that make the human experience
unique — the urge to comfort a crying baby,
savoring the flavor of food, or the simple
enjoyment of music.
And that's the heart of this film's magnetic
draw — by showing the audience our world
from an alien perspective, it makes the point
clear that the meaning of everything really
is in the eye of the beholder.
Bone Tomahawk
We like Kurt Russell.
We love horror films.
We really love Tombstone.
So when a director makes a genre-bending western
horror film starring Kurt Russell as a hard-nosed
lawman who has to defeat a clan of cannibals,
it's pretty much guaranteed that we're going
to lose our minds over it.
Bone Tomahawk is just as awesome as it sounds,
with Russell starring as Sheriff Franklin
Hunt, who must figure out how to defeat the
cannibals holed up in the "Valley of Starving
Men" before they can murder more of the citizens
of the small town he's sworn to defend.
Heck yeah!
Ex Machina
If you love science fiction films about robots
or artificial intelligence, but hate their
constantly rehashed plots, Ex Machina is the
remedy you've been searching for.
This independent movie takes common science
fiction tropes and turns them upside down,
as a computer programmer Caleb accepts an
invitation to administer the Turing intelligence
test to a humanoid robot named Ava.
What follows is an intricate plot with elements
of sci-fi, horror, psychological drama, and
thrills to keep you entertained and engaged
through numerous unexpected twists.
With exceptional writing and a stellar performance
by Alicia Vikander as Ava, Ex Machina will
keep you at the edge of your seat.
And best of all?
It has dancing!
"Tryin to find a friend."
This movie's got everything!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!